hey welcome back to the monitor I'm
Peter Rubin senior editor at Wired I
want to start off this week with a
question and that question is guess
who's back and the answer to guess whose
back is Lara Croft because a new tomb
raider game is out this week it's
actually a prequel it's been a long time
since we had a tomb raider game not
counting downloadables but i've been
waiting for this one for a while and
thankfully it pays off it is really it's
beautiful square enix and Crystal
Dynamics did a great job with it it is
kind of her before she became the
archaeologist / explore that we all know
and love and she is just an archaeology
student forced by a plane crash to
navigate a mysterious and dangerous
island really good combat better than in
previous games not as many huge deep
sprawling puzzles which I always loved
but there are a lot of little ones until
it still has that feel so if you like
third person adventure games with a
heavy dose of puzzling you're going to
love Tomb Raider in fact you already do
love to murder but you're going to love
this one too it's out this week check it
out let's talk about comics for years
now comics writer Brian Michael Bendis
has teased that he's working on this big
crossover thing for Marvel starting a
few months back people finally pieced it
together that this was going to be age
of Ultron Ultron being this supervillain
who was created back in the 60s by one
of the Avengers Hank Pym and then
banished to the far reaches of space now
this week age of Ultron is starting as a
ten issue standalone mini series coming
out weekly Ultron is back he has taken
over the planet and various Marvel
heroes have to band together and figure
out how to repel him brush him out the
door like the Sandman on live at the
Apollo at any rate it starts Varian
media rest so if you are deep into
Marvel Comics you're going to get a lot
of the relationships between these
characters if you are not you're going
to recognize people you might not know
why they're all here but this will all
come out in subsequent weeks first five
issues are drawn by Bryan Hitch the good
start it's going to be weekly so jump in
now age of Ultron number one this week
talk about music so out this week we've
got a new album from a a hot young
guitarist by the name of Jimi Hendrix
there is yes there is a new studio album
all unreleased studio material from Jimi
Hendrix who would have been 70 this year
the album is called people hell and
angels
and in the bulk of it is material that
he was working on by himself after the
Jimi Hendrix Experience broke up so
there's a lot of stuff with the drummer
buddy miles there's a lot more kind of
blues and and so work than you might
think of from his experience years he
covers an Elmore James song that's
fantastic he had played it live and then
in the weeks after that live performance
he started working on in the studio
that's just it's that kind of an album
it's all directions that he was thinking
about going for the double album that he
was making after the experience broke up
it's really nice and it doesn't feel
like one of those posthumous albums it
doesn't feel like a cash grab it doesn't
feel like Tupac's 80th album of outtakes
that got piece together over a synth
beat it's it's Jimi Hendrix tracks it's
different lineups it sounds great it's
really warm people Helen Angels out this
week from the one and only Jimi Hendrix
that is it for the monitor this week we
will actually not be back next week I'm
going to be at south by southwest in
austin all week listening and watching
things to report you about but until I
see you again inspirational catchphrase
here